comme le battement battement battement du temps
quand les ombres de la jungle tombent
comme le tic tic tac de l'
horloge majestueuse alors qu'elle se dresse contre le mur
comme la prise goutte à goutte des gouttes de pluie
quand l'été pleut
alors une voix en moi ne cesse de te répéter
toi toi nuit et jour
tu es le seul
et jour
[Musique]
sous la hauteur de moi il n'y a pas
un tel désir affamé brûlant à l'intérieur
[Musique]
mais jusqu'à ce que tu me laisses passer ma vie
à te faire l'amour jour et nuit
nuit et jour
[Musique]
vole-moi vers la lune laisse  moi chante parmi les
étoiles laisse moi
voir à quoi ressemble la vie sur moi ou sur
mars en d'autres termes
tiens ma main en d'autres termes
peut être embrasse moi
remplis mon coeur de chanson laisse moi chanter pour
toujours
si tu es tout ce que je désire pour tout ce que je vénère
et adore
en  d'autres mots s'il vous plaît être vrai
dans d'autres w  ords je t'aime
[Musique]
alors
fais
[Musique]
laisse-moi voir ce qu'est la vie
en d'autres termes en d'autres termes
je t'aime
[Musique]
bleu